es una de las mayores tragedias de
derechos humanos en méxico los 43
jóvenes de la escuela para maestros de
ayotzinapa fueron desaparecidos entre la
noche del 26 y la madrugada del 27 de
septiembre de 2014 en iguala en el
sureño estado de guerrero según la
polémica versión del anterior gobierno
de enrique peña nieto- los estudiantes
fueron detenidos por policías y
entregados al cartel guerreros unidos
que los asesinó e incineró en el
basurero de cocula tras confundirlos con
integrantes de un grupo rival
este relato conocido como la verdad
histórica fue cuestionado por los
familiares y por la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
frente a las múltiples reputaciones el
gobierno del actual mandatario andrés
manuel lópez obrador decidió abrir su
propia investigación en 2018 inaugurando
una comisión para la verdad a
identificar fuera del basurero restos no
calcinados de dos jóvenes la versión de
la verdad histórica se derrumbó
definitivamente
y el gobierno anterior que incumplió la
desaparición forzada y manipuló la
investigación para dar un cierre
precipitado por motivaciones políticas
en varios actos de protesta las familias
han denunciado que si bien valoran los
esfuerzos de la comisión de la verdad la
fiscalía general según ellos retarda las
detenciones
han hecho mucho han trabajado pero pues
para nosotros como madres y padres
sentimos que no es que va lento nosotros
quisiéramos ya que nos dijeran ya nos
encontrábamos los hijos la comisión de
la verdad da por hecho que participaron
en la desaparición de criminales y
fuerzas de seguridad de todos los
niveles así como funcionarios de la
administración pasada pero la
investigación no estaba completa sin
revelar el entorno criminal en iguala